all right bladesmiths you've made it
into the final round however your work
is not over yet we're sending you back
to your home forges to recreate an
iconic weapon from history that weapon
is
the chinese dao
referred to is the courage of all
soldiers the dao is one of china's
oldest and most revered edged weapons
for over three thousand years this
single-edged sword was carried into war
by chinese cavalry the blade's slight
curve offered its user superior
thrusting and chopping power while its
concave guard prevented enemy blood from
dripping onto the handle mounted
soldiers favored the weapon for its ease
of use on horseback often wielded at a
gallop the sword could fatally sever
enemy limbs with little resistance
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
five days
congratulations
my name is joe caltran i'm 39 years old
and i'm from cheyenne wyoming i'm casey
perdue i like working with joey lets you
make your own mistakes but he also shows
you how to correct them he said master
smith means nothing other than you've
made all the mistakes and figured out
how to fix them the challenging part on
this blade i think is going to be the
thinness of it and getting the weight
down to where i feel the judges are
going to be comfortable testing it so
the game plants forge thick and then
we'll take that meat out when it comes
to grinding i like working by hand more
i feel like i have more control but the
best thing about the power hammer is
that it saves time i think it left joe
in a pretty good spot
the quenching is nerve-wracking if you
tilt it if you turn it can cause a blade
that normally wouldn't warp to warp
it looks absolutely gorgeous
now i've got to thin the blade down
quite a bit so what i'm looking at is a
nice even balance here so that this
blade will sail through whatever it is
that they put in front of it casey
wanted to inlay pins in the ring one for
each of the competitors so we're gonna
have two pins that hold the pommel to
the tang and then six more pins in the
ring on the bottom i think it turned out
amazing it's gonna slice and dice
anything they swing it at
and there is no edge damage
my name is mark j hopper i teach
smithing from atlanta georgia my name is
jessica d collins and i've been
apprenticing with mark for four years
eventually i got good enough to help him
actually design the classes
this is almost at that point when a
master turns to his apprentice goes time
to become a journeyman this is strange
for us because i literally can't do
anything
nope you
cannot it's the hardest day's work that
i've ever had in my life and i haven't
picked up a ready hammer
jessica's put me in a fantastic place
now i would like to quench it's very
thin i'm just expecting this thing to
turn into a floppy noodle on me
this is true
no
gotta walk in there
put it between some wood drop an amble
on top of the wood
it's so straight
i need to get the ring pommel in the
back stop that [ __ ] too far again damn
it
turns out there was oh yeah
that's not gonna work
it's very very stressful
okay
low sign can't get this pommel fitted on
then
that ten thousand dollars
losing it could be my fault
placements this is the kill test to see
what kind of lethal damage your blade
will do we're gonna deliver some slashes
on this wild boar carcass joe casey
you're up first are you ready oh yeah oh
yeah i would love to wield your weapon
but i'm still
healing from an injury so
i'd like to bring in anthony palmer
and today he will be my arm
have fun
[Music]
all right joe casey off the bat it is
light you got the weight perfect on the
draw cut right here you can see that it
lacerated easily the cut here with the
spine you can see
all the nice pieces of bacon that we're
gonna make later on with this particular
carcass
your blade it will kill
good job gentlemen thank you thank you
mark jessica you're up next you ready
absolutely let's do this
all right mark jessica now your blade is
wider but the balance is light in this
particular slice
almost cut in half but definitely on the
final cut glided easily your blade is
curvaceous and sexy
and it will
thank
kill
thank you next up is a strength test
ben
blitzmans i'm going to take each of your
swords and deliver one herculean strike
on this piece of sheet metal to see how
it affects your blade
joe casey you're up you ready oh yeah oh
yeah
it's pretty good i think so this is a
beautifully light sword it's very well
balanced i like the string wrap handles
it's easy to keep a good grip on it the
edge took a little bit of dulling
there's a piece of the
sheet metal almost welded onto your
blade from the impact but it's still
very well done thank you thank you
mark jessica you guys are up you ready
indeed all right
mark jessica this is a beautiful sword
to wield it's so comfortable it's so
well balanced the steel did a little
number on your sword though there's a
chip right there but uh for such a light
and fast weapon as both of these are
actually it's it's amazing that they uh
got away this unscathed very well done
thank you
next up is the sharpness test and for
that i'll give you to dave
to test the edge of your blade and see
if it's retained that edge i'll be
cutting through these water tubes
joe casey you guys ready oh yeah let's
go for it
[Music]
joe casey your sword has
a great feel to it i like the shape of
the grip but there's that section where
that edge is rolled and that's where the
cuts started
and you can see that first tube kind of
crushed
then it starts to cut as i get up into
the sharper section up in here but then
everything had pushed over it kind of
crushed that last tube it's a beautiful
piece hold done thanks thanks
all right mark jessica you ready indeed
good job
so mark jessica you've maintained a bit
more of an edge here you can see that
cut travels through there they're clean
across the tops didn't blow out any of
the tubes didn't crush any of them
anyway a beautifully made piece it's
definitely a cutter nicely done thank
you
bladesmiths your chinese now have been
tested and the judges have evaluated the
finer details of your work and they've
made their final decision
the forged and fire champions are
mark and jessica congratulations you are
the forged and fire champions
joe and casey your weapon did not make
the cut please surrender your blade
we lost fair and square but i couldn't
have asked for a better week of learning
casey's an amazing apprentice i have no
doubt he'll be an amazing master also
mark jessica you are our new forged and
firearm champions and that's a title
that comes with a check for 10 grand
congratulations i'm blown away it's that
time please present your weapon to the
judges
it's the finish of the biggest roller
coaster ever the training that jessica
has gone through works and it can turn
somebody into one a heck of a smith it's
amazing
it's going to take a while for us to
think about it
you